bienvenue pour ce deuxième épisode arrco
aujourd'hui on va parler des groupes de
motos py qui est un sujet de recherche
extrêmement dynamique aujourd'hui dans
les mathématiques pures
donc c'est un sujet qui est vraiment
très mathématique du 20e siècle et qui
va sans doute être un grand sujet des
mathématiques aussi du 21e siècle
on les retrouve notamment un pour faire
un peu de teaser en théorie des cordes
même si je connais pas du tout la
théorie des cordes ne comptez pas sur
moi pour vous en parler
comme d'habitude il faut que je vous
dise que ceci n'est pas sa course que je
vais me permettre de dire des trucs très
approximatif voir des trucs faux le but
étant juste de d'essayer d'avoir une
idée de se tourner tout cela parle
et pourquoi ce sont des sujets vraiment
cool donc avant de commencer veut faire
un petit peu de philosophie
mathématiques fait en mathématiques
notamment poincaré s'est rendu compte
que l'on étudie en fait des objets mais
à travers souvent des représentations de
ces objets notamment poincaré a pas mal
étudié le plan hyperbolique
il s'est rendu compte qu'en fait que le
plan hyperbolique fait c'est un truc
qu'on peut imaginer exister dans un
espèce de monde platonicien au monde des
idées quoi mais on ne peut vraiment
l'étudier qu'à travers des
représentations de ce monde et c'est ce
dont on a pas mal parlé notamment dans
l'épisode 9 p reprendre épisode 12 le
monde hyperbolique on peut leur
présenter de manière extrême sec de
manière intrinsèque ou à l'aide de
cartes notamment de la carte de poincaré
qu'on appelle le disque de poincaré donc
poincaré s'est rendu compte que souvent
c'est merveilleux objet mathématique on
y avait accédé de différentes manières
et que l'une des grandes difficultés des
mathématiques
c'était de pouvoir se rendre compte que
lorsqu'on utilise deux choses
différentes en fait on parle de la même
chose et tout ce qu'on prouve pour l'un
et en fait transférables pour l'autre
mais ça c'est super utile car il ya
certains trucs à propos de cet objet
fondamentales qui sont vraiment
difficiles d'accès avec une certaine
représentation du plan hyperbolique mais
qui deviennent presque évident quand on
utilise la bonne représentation de
l'espace hyperbolique donc par exemple
l'existence des triangles idéaux dont
j'ai parlé dans l'épisode 12 et je
croise une ride commentaires de
l'épisode 13 c'est un truc qui est
impossible de soutien pour moi se le
représenter avec la visio extrinsèque ou
la vision intrinsèque de la géométrie
hyperbolique par contre qu'on utilise
disque de poincaré ça devient presque
évident que du coup un des grands jeux
des mathématiques selon poincaré et
c'est quelque chose qui aura beaucoup
influencé la pensée des mathématiciens
du 20e siècle est maintenant du 21e
siècle c'est de réussir à identifier les
objets platonicien que qui sont derrière
les objets que l'on étudie vraiment en
pratique et de montrer qu'en fait de
construction qu'on a fait en
mathématiques sont fait les mêmes et
parle d'un même objet platonicien c'est
un peu une vision platonicienne des
mathématiques moi personnellement en
fait je suis même pas si platonicien que
ça donc c'est pas forcément une vision
véritablement vrai mais c'est une vision
qui a incroyablement utile en tout cas
pour parler de l'homme au topic
bref tout ce que j'ai dit ah c'est juste
pour vous expliquer ce que je comprend
en tout cas quand poincaré disait que la
mathématique et l'art de donner le même
nom à des choses différentes et du coup
une fois qu'on commence à raisonner
comme cela
la tension ne devrait pas être sur les
représentations que l'on se fait d'un
objet platonicien mais plutôt sur les
propriétés fondamentales de cet objet
platonicien que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les représentations de cet objet
platonicien ses propriétés fondamentales
de l'objet platonicien ce sont ce qu'on
appelle parfois des invariants donc un
exemple d'un variant en géométrie
hyperbolique c'est que si vous prenez
une géométrie hyperbolique alors la
somme des angles de tout triangle va
être toujours inférieure à 180 degrés
donc si vous avez plusieurs
représentations différentes de ce plan
hyperbolique alors dans toutes ses
représentations
si vous calculez la somme des angles des
triangles 7 vous devez toujours obtenir
moins que 180 degrés c'est un invariant
car c'est une propriété fondamentale de
l'objet platonicien que tous ces héros
présentation du plan hyperbolique
possède
ceci dit ce n'est pas un invariant
caractéristique c'est à dire qu'il ya
d'autres objets platonicien qu'ils ont
aux aussi nous sommes des angles des
triangles qui qui est un phare à 180
degrés mais qui ne sont pas exactement
le plan hyperbolique donc un invariant
et pas forcément caractéristiques
par exemple le fait que la somme des
angles des fins bien faire à 180 n'est
pas caractéristique du plan hyperbolique
il yad'autres géométrie qui ont aussi
des hommes sommes des angles inférieures
à 190
mais il ya des invariants qui eux sont
caractéristiques par exemple le fait que
la courbure de gosses partout dans
l'espace est égal à -1
ça c'est une avarie caractéristique qui
fait que si une géométrie satisfait
cette propriété alors c'est le plan
hyperbolique donc un invariant
caractéristique permet d'identifier
uniquement l'objet platonicien dont on
parle ok donc là je parlais de géométrie
par bolide pour illustrer un peu ses
idées mais ce dont on va vraiment parler
aujourd'hui ce sont des variétés
topologique donc une variété topologique
une espèce de formes géométriques un qui
peut de dimension un des émotions 2 2
millions 3 2 dimensions 14 mai dans
cette forme géométrique qu'il n'ya pas
d'angle il n'y a pas de distance et il
n'y a pas de droite donc une variété
topologique c'est ce que l'on peut
obtenir à partir d'une variété
géométriques
lorsque l'on oublie ces considérations
qui sont vraiment géométriques
donc en gros une variété topologique
c'est un truc qui est intuitive en plus
simple qu'il va arrêter géométriques qui
a moins de structures qu'une variété
géométriques pour en savoir plus je vous
invite à aller voir l'excellent épisode
de patience à ce sujet sur les surfaces
et les tolérer topologie et donc comme
j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode 25 des
grandes questions de poincaré c'était
quels étaient les différentes variétés
topologique deux dimensions 2-2 dimanche
3 et ainsi de suite et donc pas la
dimension de deux points car et a résolu
le problème il à déterminer toutes les
variétés topologique en tout cas celle
qui était compacte par contre pour la
dimension 3 c'est un problème qui encore
ouvert aujourd'hui qui est assez assez
difficile alors pour étudier ces
variétés topologique qu'il a pour le
coup lui vraiment dans un monde
platonicien qui est très très très très
difficile d'accès pour qu'elles
utilisent des modèles d des
représentations ces objets topologique
c'est platonicien donc par exemple pour
se représenter la deux sphères la sphère
topologique il va utiliser la
représentation d'une de ce père
géométriques donc là deux sphères
géométrique est une façon de décrire la
deux sphères topologique en fait il y en
a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'autres et
ça ça veut dire que certaines propriétés
de la sphère géométriques ne seront
peut-être pas forcément des propriétés
de la sphère topologique il faut
vraiment faire gaffe quand on étudie la
sphère géométriques ne pas trop
généralisée des trucs à la sphère
topologique qui ne sont en fait pas gêné
lisa bhl et donc pour éviter de telles
erreurs pour guéret propose d'étudier
des invariants de la sphère topologique
est un des invariants qu'elle y pense
c'est le groupe fondamentale à savoir
l'ensemble des lacets aux motos pis près
alors ça fait beaucoup de cours aux mots
pour commenter ces coins là c'est un
lacet intuitivement c'est un chemin qui
va revenir sur lui-même dans la variété
topologique poincaré se rend compte que
l'on peut décrire cela c'est comme une
fonction continue de l'intervalle 0,1
dans la variété topologique donc il faut
imaginer qu'à chaque instant du temps ce
chemin prend une certaine valeur dans la
variété topologique à certains endroits
d'un vérité topologique et pour que ça
soit un lacet il faut qu'il revienne sur
lui-même du coup on va demander à ce que
valeur de cette fonction en zéro soit
égal à sa valeur en une façon plus jolie
de réclère ça peut ne pas avoir cette
égalité qui traîne qui consiste à dire
que un lacet c'est une fonction du
cercle s1 s annonçait le cercle du
cercle dans la variété topologique une
des grandes idées de poincaré c'était
aussi de dire que de lacets sont parfois
en fait les mêmes même s'ils ont l'air
différent en fait fondamentalement ce
sont mêmes et ça c'est le cas lorsque
l'on peut transformer de façon continue
l'un en l'autre ce qu'on appelle une
moto pis donc nos motos pis d'un point
de vue plus mathématique
ça correspond à une fonction qui va être
paramétré par quelque chose je continue
donc une fonction de 0,1 dans l'ensemble
des lacets tels que le lacet qui a
obtenu en 0 h2o va être le lacet de
départ un des deux lacets et la valeur
en soi l'autre la scène s'il existe une
telle fonction h
une telle aux motos pis entre deux
lacets alors on dit que les deux lacets
sont homos top et donc pour contrecarrer
ce sont en fait les mêmes et donc on
peut en revenir au groupe fondamental au
fond d'un talent c'est l'ensemble des
lacets aux motos pis près c'est à dire
que c'est l'ensemble des lacets mais de
là c'est dans ce groupe sont en fait
égaux
s'ils sont homos top6 l'issue nos motos
py qui permet de passer de l'un à
l'autre alors dans le cas de la sphère
comme on en a parlé dans l'épisode 25 le
groupe fondamental de la sphère est en
fait trivial c'est à dire qu'il ne
contient qu'un seul élément le lacet
trivial ou autrement dit si vous prenez
n'importe quel lacets de la sphère je
veux pour retrouver nos motos
pis qui va déformer cela c'est et le
réduire en un point donc dans le cas de
la sphère le groupe fondamentale est
super simple cependant dans le cas du
tort le bouffon mental est assez
compliquée puisque en fait il y est
infinie du coup ça pourrait difficile
d'étudier un objet qui est infini bien
ce qui va nous sauver qui va nous
permettre de quand même bien compris en
fait le groupe fondamentale du tort
c'est le fait qu'il y a une structure
algébrique très simple sur l'ensemble
des lacets du tort et cette structure
algébrique a été découverte par poincaré
c'est ce qu'on appelle la composition
des lacets donc tout simplement bancaire
et dit que si j'ai deux lacets je peux
les combinés en suivant le premier puis
le deuxième et ça fera au final un autre
la scène donc ça ça nous permet de
combiner des lacets entre eux un peu
comme combinerait dénombre à travers
l'addition pour former un troisième
nombre une petite différence entre cette
opération et l'addition des nombreux
classiques c'est le fait que cette
opération de composition est en général
pas commutative c'est à dire qu'en
général si je fais l heure l 2 c'est à
dire je fais d'abord la boucle l1 puis
après je suis le lacet l2 là c'est que
j'aurais fait et pas forcément le même
que si je fais l de l1 c'est d'abord la
selle depuis de la c1 et ce même à
automoto pis presse je peux même pas
passé avec nos motos pis de l1 l2 à
elles deux elles ont dit que la
composition des lacets n'est pas
commutative parfois on dit qu'elle n'est
pas ab yens alors il se trouve que cette
composition est parfaitement compatible
avec la relation domoto pis et ça ça
veut dire que si je considère les
compositions à homo topi près ça me fait
un groupe valides ou l'opération de
composition va être valide aussi pour
les plus l objet briest parmi vous ce
que je suis en train de dire c'est que
si on consciente le groupe des lacets
par la relation de motos pis j'obtiens
encore une fois un groupe et du coup ça
ça veut dire que l'on peut étudier les
variétés théologique dont quelque chose
de très continue parlato des groupes
discrète dont quelque chose qui est très
facile à calculer à combiner leur
histoire ce qui est amusant c'est que
poincaré quasiment dû s'excuser de cela
parce qu'en fait la théorie des groupes
de base elle a étudié
des formations d'un objet j'avais parlé
de cette théorie des groupes dans le
documentaire sur les maths de prépa sauf
que là a priori ce que décrit point qui
reste n'est pas des déformations de quoi
que ce soit ce sont des lacets des des
chemins donc il n'ya pas de déformation
cependant les axiomes caractéristiques
des groupes de transformation étaient
très semblables aux propriétés
caractéristiques de ses compositions des
lacets du coupon carrez a affirmé dans
son dans l'analyse si tu sais il a écrit
que tout se passe vraiment comme si on
était dans un groupe du coup je vais
appeler ça un groupe même si ce n'est
pas vraiment un groupe
aujourd'hui on définit les groupes
autrement qu'à l'époque définit
aujourd'hui les groupes par leurs
propriétés du coup aujourd'hui on
m'appellera c'est un groupe sans se
poser de questions du coup c'est amusant
de voir que cette invention d'un nouveau
groupe a fait avancer la manière dont on
définit les groupes et donc dont on
comprend les groupes en général
on va illustrer tout ça maintenant avec
un exemple à l'exemple du tort dans le
cas du tort le groupe fondamentale en
fait il est généré par deux lacets de
base qui l'un qui consiste à aller vers
l'autre vers la droite dans la
représentation en car et dont les côtés
sont collés est tout autre la selva être
en fait une composition de ces deux là
c'est là et se trouve en plus que dans
le cas du tort
l'opération de composition est toujours
habillé n'est toujours commutative c'est
à dire que si je prends deux là c'est un
gamin et gamma 2 du tort à leurs gamins
un rond gamma 2 va être égal à au bouton
puis prêt à gamma deux ronds gamma et du
coup ça veut dire que tout la scène du
tort aux motos puis près s'écrit comme
des compositions de gamins gamme à deux
gamins gamme à 2 on peut aussi faire l'
inverse affaires gamin 1 dans le sens
opposé donc on a des gars me -1 gamma 2
- 1 etc et à l'aide de la commune tati
vite et on peut ramener tous les gammes
à 1
au début tous les megaman 2 à la fin et
gamma un el gammas 1 - 1 vont s'annuler
si je fais un tour dans un sens puis je
reviens c'est comme si on va dire et pas
bougé pareil pour les gammes de et donc
à la fin à la faim général des éléments
du groupe fondamentale du tort ce sont
des éléments de la forme gamins puissent
en scène gamma deux puissances m
autrement dit tous là c'est à au motel
plus près du tort correspond à une paire
dentier haine et aime et vous pourrez
être un peu plus technique existe une
direction entre l'ensemble des lacets à
homo topi près et l'ensemble des
perdantes y relatifs et pour aller
encore un peu plus loin cette direction
conserve l'opération de composition
c'est à dire que si je prends gamma
impuissance m
cama deux puissances n gamin impuissance
pm1 de puissance qu et moi je vais
pouvoir combiner ça va me faire gamma
impuissance m plus p gama deux
puissances elles plus qu du coup la
composition de sites correspondait à m
n et pq va donner m + paix et une puce q
du coup la composition des lacets
correspond à une a dit
sion dans l'ensemble des perdantes y
relatifs on dit que cette opération qui
consiste à associer kaman gamana mn est
un isomorphisme de groupe et
intuitivement ça correspond à dire qu'en
fait ces deux groupes là sont en gros
les mêmes pour ça que si vous lisez des
bouquins de maths
vous lirez parfois le goût fondamentale
du tort ap pire de t2 qui est égal
parfois ils mettent isomorphe à z car et
en particulier ce qu'on a prouvé ici
c'est que contrairement à la sphère le
groupe fondamentale du tort n'est pas
trivial du coup go fondamentale du thor
est différent du groupe fondamental de
la sphère et ça ça prouve que la sphère
le tort ne sont pas les mêmes objets
même dans le monde platonicien des
variétés topologique donc le groupe
fondamentale est un invariant qui permet
de distinguer les variétés topologique
qui ont des groupes fondamentaux
différents la question de points qui
reste celle inverse de savoir si je
prends deux variétés topologique
différents est-ce que leur groupe
fondamentaux vont être différent aussi
et ça malheureusement en général ce
n'est pas le cas du coupon guerra a
simplifié la question si demandé est ce
que le fait que le groupe fondamentale
d'une vérité compact et trivial je peux
être défini ce qui était compacte et ça
on va dire finissant bord est ce que
dans ce cas le fait que le bon fond d'un
mental et trivial et caractéristiques de
la haine ce faire en dimension humaine
ça c'est exactement la conjecture de
poincaré ce qui est amusant c'est que
historiquement poincaré là d'abord pour
eux et pour la dimension de ça c'était
sera pas facile mais c'était faisable
puis après il a laissé la question
ouverte par dimension 3 10 ans cette
question nous emmènerait trop loin et au
cours du 20e siècle les mathématiciens
les topologies sont aussi à prouver que
pour des sphères suffisamment grandes
dimensions suffisamment grande
le gros fondamentale était
caractéristique de la sphère mais il
n'arrivait pas à le prouver pour des
espaces de dimensions plus petites ce
qui est amusant c'est que les dépenses
sont plus grands n'étaient plus facile
que les dimensions plus petites bons ils
ont fini par réussir à le prouver pour
la dimension 5 après 10 mois sont quatre
et puis restait plus qu'à dimension 3 et
puis finalement c'est pire allemagne qui
a prouvé le cas de la dimension de 3 en
2003 et un autre truc qui est amusant
c'est la manière dont père allemagne est
arrivé en fait il a suivi le programme
de leur stone
qui avait conjectures et notamment que
si je comprends n'importe quel espace de
dimension 3 alors on pouvait le jo
maîtrisé c'est à dire lui donner une
géométrie parmi huit diome très
différentes
depuis il a montré que cette conjecture
de géométrisation était très relier est
intimement liée à la conjecture de
poincaré
mais ça c'est remarquable qu'il y en ait
un lien juste un nombre fille puis 8
comme ça en dimensions 2 il y en a trois
et le fait qu'on rajoute une dimension
savent ajoute un peu de variété sur la
troisième dimension notamment le penseur
de heijmans par exemple beaucoup plus
grand tu sais ça veut pas dire que les
géométrie euclidienne par exemple sont
toutes les mêmes géométrie par exemple
le tort n'a pas vraiment la même
géométrie que le plan puisque par
exemple dans un tort c'est une continue
toujours dans une direction ou finissait
par revenir besoin d'un endroit alors
que dans le plan vous continuez à
l'infini mais la géométrie c'est à dire
la courbure va être là même ses arcs les
triangles toujours c'est donc des angles
égal à 180 degrés ou plus exactement si
vous me donnez un tort mais il existe
une manière pour moi de déformer le tort
de lui donner une géométrie tels que la
somme des angles vautours 180 devait
donc ce que first and voulais dire c'est
que si vous me donner n'importe quelle
forme
topologique et je vais pouvoir mettre
une géométrie c'est à dire pouvoir
déformer cette forme topologique pour en
faire une variété géométriques dont la
courbure en tout point était uniforme et
était l'une des huit géométrie nos
forces
sauf que first n avait pas forcément de
bonnes idées de savoir comment est ce
qu'on pouvait vraiment déformer les
choses en pratique comment est-ce qu'on
peut définir la manière dont on va
déformer la variété topologique pour
obtenir cette géométrie uniforme
donc ça ça a conduit à un autre
mathématicien richard hamilton a lancé
un nouveau programme une nouvelle idée
de de manière de prouver la conjecture
de poincaré et puis la candidature des
jeux maîtrise à sion de first and en
partant d'une géométrie quelconque sur
votre pari théologique et en essayant de
la gonfler imaginez vous prenez un
ballon de foot qui est pas gonfler des
bulles ressemble pas du tout à nice
faire puisque hamilton propose de faire
c'est de gonfler de souffler dans le
ballon et on a observé un observe
empiriquement que un ballon quand on
souffre quand on essaie d'homogénéiser
sa courbure partout on finit par obtenir
une sphère c'est à dire une géométrie
très connus classe que je vous raconte
glace et les super vulgariser ça al'air
impossible de passer de sauber maths
mais on a vu en fait les outils
nécessaires déjà dans l'épisode hardcore
précédent l'outil le plus important fait
ça va être le temps soeur de richie le
temps soeur de richie il donne la
moyenne des courbures dans dans chacune
des directions
il est l'intensité en fait de la
courbure va être directement relié à la
taille de du repaire de coordonner qu'on
a choisi en un point donné
du coup juste en allongeant ou en
rétrécissant les longueurs des repères
en fait on modifie alors la géométrie de
de la variété toute logique et en
particulier on modifie les valeurs du
tenseur de riemann donc de la courbure
et du tenseur de richie et orly d'idées
de fersen c'est de faire en sorte que la
courbure dans toutes les directions
somogy niçois aussi pareil que possible
et ça ça veut dire qu'il va rétrécir la
longueur d'un repère si la courbure dans
cette direction est très grande
la façon formelle de dire ce que je
viens de dire c'est à dire que la
variation du tenseur métriques va être
l'opposé du tenseur de réty m'ont
parfois on rajoute un facteur 2 parfois
modifier encore un peu les collations
pour pas que ses repères dans le vert 0
ou tend vers l'infini mais l'idée est
vraiment dans cette équation de base en
tout cas cette équation c'est ce qu'on
appelle le flot de haïti et
intuitivement il correspond vraiment à
gonfler un chauffe et la géométrie de
l'espace pour pour lui faut remiser
autant que possible en tout cas c'est ce
que représentent ces ex en d'image
d'image des maths par patrick massot et
à tianjin
c'est joli comme ça ça a l'air facile et
view mais quand on regarde les détails
mathématiques on tombe sur des énormes
équation à dérivées partielles qui sont
un peu difficiles
cette équation duflot d'oreiller en
pratique toutefois elle pose pas mal de
problèmes notamment il peut y avoir des
points où les coordonnées qu'on dessine
le temps soeur métriques finissent par
se réduire à néant ou par exploser à ce
moment-là on est des singularités et
c'est la catastrophe
du coup faut absolument éviter ces
singularités et pour éviter ces
singularités
une façon de faire qu'on appelle la
chirurgie topologique consiste à couper
l'endroit où va y avoir cette
singularité pour la recoller à un autre
endroit où elle posera moins de problème
donc pour en savoir plus je vous invite
à aller voir ce super épisode de
patience qui nous parlera notamment de
la somme connectés et pour aller encore
un peu plus loin je vous invite à aller
voir cette vidéo de number five sur le
flot de richie est donc le génie de
perelman c'est entre autres moi je
comprends rien sa pomme mais entre
autres apparemment c'est d'avoir su
couper les endroits où qu'ils allaient
poser problème pour mieux les coller aux
autres endroits et avoir ainsi résolu
tous les problèmes de singularité et
ainsi l'a prouvé la conjecture deux
soeurs stone et au passage il a donc
aussi prouvé la conjecture de poincaré
revenons-en au fondamental donc le
beaufortain je vous ai dit que poincaré
étaient très réticents à l'idée de
l'appeler c'est un groupe parce que ce
n'était pas un ensemble de permutations
ça c'était à l'époque mais faisons pas
mal évolué aujourd'hui et depuis on
interprète aisément le groupe de
poincaré comme étant la manière de repli
le revêtement universel pour obtenir une
topologie données et si on veut
simplifier on va commencer avec un
exemple très simple la dimension un an
dimension à une variabilité topolino
dimension tivement espèce de tracés au
stylo peu et si je vous dis qu'il existe
une seule variété topologique deux
dimensions un qui soit simplement
connexes king qui n'est pas de boucle
vous voyez à quoi je pense n'est qu'une
seule vous voyez je vais je souhaitais
faire un petit peu en fait la seule
variété pop logique dimension un
simplement connexes c'est la droite ou
enfin un chemin qui continuent à l
infini mais qui continue sans fin et ça
ça va être du coup ce qu'on appelle le
revêtement universel de dimensions 1 et
une représentation de cette variété
topologie de dimension un simplement
connexes c'est la droite des réelles et
là on voit bien sur la droite des
réelles que si on prend n'importe quel
là c'est à dire un lacet qui commence à
un point qui revient sur ce point eh ben
on peut réduire de façon moto pic cela
c'est assez triviale avec une simple
homothétie par rapport à 0 en quoi c'est
une nouveauté 6 par rapport à 0 bar on
obtient la cei qui va être égal à zéro
mais il existe une autre variété
topologique différentes deux dimensions
vous voyez lequel le cercle le cercle et
de dimensions montrant qu on se regarde
us la ligne parce qu'il irait à
l'intérieur sauf qu'à la différence
entre le cercle et la droite c'est que
la sphère à leur boucle sur elle même
est en fait d'un point de vue au mot
topic
on peut considérer par exemple la sec
qui fait le tour sas avec un lacet nom
tribal qu'on peut pas réduire en un
point de façon continue en fait en y
réfléchissant un petit peu tout la scène
en trivial
du cercle correspond à faire ça fondre
de tours soit dans le sens soir soit
dans le sens antihoraire est en fait
l'application qui a un lacet associe son
nombre de tours est un iso morphisme
entre le groupe fondamentale du cercle
et l'ensemble des entier qui compte le
nombre de tours donc le groupe
fondamentale p12 au sein du cercle et
isomorphe à z tout ce que je viens de
dire peu sera interprétée en termes de
repliement de la drogue aurait donc
imaginant que là j'ai un bout de la
droite dès real qui continuent à
l'infini peu et parce que ce qu'on va
faire s'est replié ce à cenon z dont z
nous dit que le point 0,10 e + 0 et là
et le point 1 doivent être identifiés
doit être ramené au même point et vous
verrez que si je fais ça naturellement
il va se créer une boucle comme ça donc
ça ça correspond à dire que je vais
identifier le point zéro avec le point 1
parce que le point 1 et correspond à la
translation d'une unité de zéro vers la
droite
donc ça c'était pour un sauf qu'il faut
faire ça pour tous les éléments de z
donc si je fais 2 translation ça me
donne à partir de zéro c'est me donne
deux tuque une fois identifiés 0 et 2
donc ça veut dire que ce point la doite
à nouveau identifié à ce point là et hop
voilà on obtient un cercle sas enroule
parfaitement et donc si je continuais
comme ça je prends de desserte un peu
plus pour que ça soit un peu plus
visible mais vous voyez que le lorsque
l'on repli la droite des réels par
rapport à cette symétrie de translation
de la droite est réel j'obtiens le
cercle est inverse je peut déplier le
cercle selon son groupe fondamentale en
disant que mondiaux je prends ce point
là ce point là si je fais une boucle
comme ça j'ai envie de dire que
j'obtiens un point différent bon fait
j'obtiens le vrai point dans le cercle
mais s'ils ont envie de déplier le
cercle envie de dire que après un tour
j'obtiens nouveaux points du coup je
vais séparer ses deux pouces ce point-là
du poids qui est obtenue en faisant un
tour dans le sens au vert et si je
distingue ces deux points ça me revient
à déplier le cercle et si je veux
continuer à déplier des deux tours c'est
pas pareil que
un tour donc je continue à déplier et au
fur et à mesure je fini par obtenir la
droite des réels autrement dit si je
regarde le l'ensemble des points du
cercle n'est que je regarde aussi
donc si je multiplie sa part le groupe
fondamentale donc les lacets qui sont
différents j'obtiens dépliement du
cercle qui est la droite des réelles
donc est ce un croix nouveau
fondamentale du s1 est en fait isomorphe
à la droite des réels est il là je faire
un truc qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire
normalement mais ça marche dans ce cas
je vais divisé des deux côtés par le
gault fondamentale et là je vois que s1
et isomorphe à la droite des réelles
cocciante est pas bien de s 1 confondant
talent du siècle dont on a vu que ça a
été le groupe des antilles relatifs donc
là dans la manière dont sont à présenter
le cercle ici à présent que c'est adapté
au web en fait bien souvent en
mathématiques avancées on va considérer
ceci comme en fait la définition du
cercle ce qui est marrant parce que le
la dans cette définition du cercle il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas de plan clients
kapaya pas de r2 qu'on n'a pas pu vous
plonger le cercle à l'intérieur d'un
espace de dimensions de du cercle juste
existe en tant que façon de replier
pas forcément dans l'expression
métriques la droite des réelles d'un
point de vue peut-être un peu plus
formel en fait ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a pris la droite derrière et on a
considéré un groupe qui agit sur la
droite des réelles donc le groupe des
sentiers z
donc il agit en faisant des translations
d'une unité de deux unités de moins
unités et c est donc dans cette image
pire de l'ès 1 leveaux fondamentale du
cercle et bien un groupe de
transformation un groupe de permutations
de la droite des réelles du revêtement
universel et le cercle est défini en
fait parce qu'on obtient lorsqu'on prend
le revêtement universel qu'est la droite
des réels et que l'on cocciante par le
groupe qui a agi sur sa droite le group
cède du coup dans cette image si je
prends un petit morceau du cercle s'ils
essaient de le représenter sur son
revêtement universel ça va correspondre
à plein de petits morceaux disjoint en
particulier un point va être représentée
par plein de points 10 juin sur la
droite des réels ces petits points dit
joint cet ensemble de points de juin
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fibre de ce
point du cercle donc la fibre de ce
point ça fait dix morts faisaient danser
ensemble de points claude comme ça c'est
discret ce c'est simple et facile à
visualiser mais notamment en médecine
quantique et en particulier son appel en
théorie des jauges on n'étudie pas mal
des fibres qui sont des groupes encore
là c'est un groupe z mais on peut
prendre d'autres groupes mais en théorie
des vosges on va prendre souvent des
groupes qui sont continue alors ce qui
va se passer notamment mécanique
quantique c'est que le revêtement
universelle c'est quelque chose que qui
est assez simple là c'est la droite des
réelles ça est un espace type mans et
rennes truc assez simple mais l'espace
qui nous intéresse vraiment l'espace ici
s1 qui en fait un espace platonicien des
solutions des équations de la mécanique
quantique
cet espace là il est difficile
attendre on peut le représenter et de
différentes manières et chaque façon de
la représenter plus parfois on va
décrire une même solution dans cette
image in dans ce monde platonicien sauf
que comme on peut pas accéder
directement à cenon platonicien on
s'intéresse souvent aux présentations
que l'on peut faire nous de saumon
platonicien et qui ont qui sont plus
faciles à calculer
mais du coup on sait que dans ce monde
plus facile à calculer dans ce monde
plus calculatoire on peut avoir
plusieurs représentations du même objet
tout comme ici différents points d'une
fibre représenterait un même objet de
l'objet platonicien le plus flou c'est
quand juste en supposant que le groupe
qui correspond à une fibre n'est pas ici
un groupe discret comme z mais un groupe
continue qui va être par exemple de un
ensemble de rotation du plan on en
déduit juste de fait qui essaie cette
symétrie dans l'ensemble des modèles
calculatoire nand et de nier l'existence
d'un objet fondamentale qui est le
photon l'électromagnétisme et déduit du
fait du choix de la fibre dans l'espace
calculatoire c'est juste incroyable
de la même façon si on considère qu' il
ya une fibre est su de 3 dans l'espace
de calcul on en détruit l'existence dans
l'espace platonicien de la force forte
et il ya un truc à peu près similaire
aussi avec la force faible avec mais qui
est plus compliqué avec le groupe est de
2 tout ce que je viens de dire notamment
pour issus de trois ici c'est des trucs
de physiciens alors que tout n'est pas
forcément prouver et en fait prouvé que
la sud iii permet d'impliquer une
théorie de la force forte tant d'églises
et montrer certaines propriétés cellules
notamment qu'ils acquièrent de la masse
on un terrain glissant entre eux c'est
l'un des problèmes du minium le problème
de deux ans et demi après
de là je dis ça comme ça pour être
honnête avec vous je ne maîtrise pas du
tout toutes ces histoires le théorie des
champs et la théorie des jauges ce n'est
pas sain peut complètement et du coup je
pense pas que c'est moi qui va empocher
les millions de dollars
revenons-en à des trucs plus simple avec
le gros avantage de cela on a vu la
dimension 1 maintenant passer au cas de
la dimension de le plus simple qui est
le tort le tort il un groupe
fondamentale qui est qu'on la dit
isomorphe à z de à l'ensemble des pères
dentier donc si on prend un surface
carrée et concerts maintenant un lacet
qui va vers le haut et qui revient sur
le dépit cela c'est ça va nous permettre
de dessiner un nouveau point et du coup
on va avoir un nouvel élément de la
fibre du tort dans le revêtement
universel et si on déplie souvenons tous
les lacets et ben on voit que l'on
construit ainsi un plan aux clients est
en fait le revêtement universel du torse
et le plan un client ou autrement dit si
on prend le plan un client c'est-à-dire
r2 avec deux repères r croit m
si on cocciante cet espace r2 par le
groupe fondamentale du tort c'est à dire
z2 ça ça va être isomorphe otor et du
coup une façon de définir le tort ou de
torts topologie comme moi c'est de
définir comme étant t2 est égal à air 2
/ z 2 c'est pas la seule façon de faire
une autre façon qui est assez classique
de définir le tort c'est de voir que le
taux en fait si on a un cercle dans une
direction et à un autre cercle dans une
autre direction
du coup on peut en fait définir le tort
comme étant le produit cartésien entre
un cercle un cercle
autrement dit t2 en fait isomorphe as 1
3 1 et comme on a vu que le cercle s1
était égal à r quot santé par z on en
fait
r cocciante et par z au caire et qui
isole morph ar 2 / z deux salaires
évident qu'on l'écrit comme ça mais là
on n'est pas en train de manipuler des
no en train de
manipuler des ensembles des espaces
topologique et du coup l'égalité là est
beaucoup moins évidente
il est vrai est en fait cette
construction là on l'a fait en
dimensions 2 mais en fait on peut la
faire dans n'importe quelle dimension
est en fait le tort de dimension n on
peut le définir comme le produit
cartésien de haine cercle de dimensions
1 remarque d'ailleurs au passage que si
on remplace scène par un on voit qu'en
fait le tort de dimension est le cercle
des dimensions les deux sont fait les
mêmes et on voit aussi que s la
puissance n est en fait un zoom of arn
cocciante et par z puissance n 1 car on
va maintenant essayer de comprendre un
peu plus exactement ce qui s'est passé
quand on a cocciante et le plan inclut
bien par z 2 et on va utiliser cette
construction ensuite pour passer à la
construction d'une autre variété
topologique qui va être beaucoup plus
intrigante que le tort mais pour en
arriver là d'abord on va essayer de bien
comprendre ce qui se passe quand
cocciante r2 par 7 2 en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'on a considéré que
z 2 était un groupe qui a agi c'est sur
le plan plus exactement on a considéré 2
transformations du plan chacun
correspondant un là c'est différent
la première c'est une translation vers
la droite
je vais appeler ça sigma boixe et mieux
une transformation du passé loin d'une
permutation des points du plan déplacent
tous les points du plan de d'autres
points du plan et on a considéré une
autre translation du plan qui était
consiste à aller vers le haut d'une
unité qu'on peut appeler tôt donc si on
prend juste si my tho là on n'a pas
encore un groupe de transformation pour
avoir tout un groupe de transformation
il faut que l'on puisse combiné sigma et
aux dons qu'on va considérer aussi
toutes les combinaisons de sigma veto et
là on voit très bien que la translation
quelque chose de cool imitatif entre
slatter à droite plus vers le haut c'est
la même chose que transiter vers l'eau
puis vers la droite
dans ce groupe aussi on va autoriser les
inverse c'est-à-dire au lieu d'avancer
vers la droite on voit faire l'opération
qui annule sig ben yadir la translation
vers la gauche
si vous avez une translation garde
droite on peut annuler sa en faisant la
transition vers la gauche ça on
l'appelle ça souvent sigma monza la même
façon on va courir et au moins un qui à
translation vers le bas
si on considère toutes les combinaisons
docile bateau silva - et au moins 1
là on a vraiment un groupe un groupe de
transformation et ce groupe commutatif
mais comme on l'a vu avec les lacets
précédemment il est izotov à z 2 puisque
chaque élément de ce groupe s'écrit
sigma puissant cm x tôt puissance n est
donc en fait quand on dit qu'on
cautionne r2 par z2 vaz que l'on dit
vraiment c'est que l'on cocciante le
plan le client par le groupe engendrés
par ces deux translation sigma eto'o et
ce groupe engendrés par sigma tau étant
isomorphe à z 2 on fait souvent un
raccourci en disant que c'est par z de
que l'on cocciante
ok si vous dis tout ça c'est que
maintenant on va faire une petite
modification à ce que je viens de dire
en remplaçant la translation vers le
haut taux par une symétrie glissé on va
appeler euros donc la symétrie glissé
que je vous principe propose de
considérer consiste à faire une symétrie
une réflexion par rapport à la x x et y
alain demi suivi d'une translation vers
le haut cette fois on peut remarquer que
sigma héros ne communique pas c'est à
dire si on fait d'abord une translation
vers la droite d'une unité puis la
réflexion par rapport à l'axé x et
galles en demi puis on va vers le haut
donc si on fait sigma pur au ca seront
écrits sarraut consigli parce qu'on
commençait opération à droite on obtient
globalement une réflexion par rapport à
laax désordonnée avec une translation
vers le haut à l'inversion fait sygma
ont rossé dire on commence par la
réflexion axial par rapport à l'aqsiq
ségalen demi puis on fait cette
translation vers le haut puis après on
fait la translation vers la droite d'une
unité qui correspond à sylvain ne tient
globalement la réflexion glissé par
rapport à laax x égale 1-1 et avec une
translation d'une unité vers l'eau ça ça
change pas mais du coup rossi l'humain
est cette fois différente de si guy
marrot seen by renault comuto pas est en
fait le groupe engendrés par eau et
sigma va être non un bilan non
commutative cependant il ya quand même
une relation intime entre euros et sygma
qui va falloir comprendre si on veut
bien comprendre ce groupe
après tout on voit que rossi dumas et
sigmar oh c'est pas si différent et en
fait je vous propose de calculer sigma
moins un gros c'est à dire qu'on va
faire d'abord la réflexion glissé par
rapport à l'excellent aqsiq ségalen demi
puis à translation vers le haut puis on
va appliquer sigma - 1 c'est à dire
qu'on va faire une translation vers la
gauche d'une unité est là lorsque l'on
fait ça on voit que globalement ce que
l'on ne tient c'est bien une réflexion
glissé par rapport à alex désordonnée
avec une translation d'une unité vers le
haut ça c'est exactement ce que l'on
avait obtenu lorsqu'on avait calculé
rossi dumas du coup on a une relation
fondamentale entre euros et sygma qui
consiste à se dire que rossi goy est
égal à sygma moins un euro
et en fait cette relation à l'identifier
uniquement le groupe
c'est à dire que tout groupe engendrés
par deux éléments et qui satisfait cette
relation va être isomorphe au groupe
engendrés par les transformations un sim
aéro
donc on écrit que le groupe aujourd'hui
par sigma héros c'est égal aux gros
engendrés par a et b ou à va jouer le
rôle d'euros et b va jouer le rôle de
sylvain tels que on à la relation bea
est égal à à - 1 b ce qu'elle appelle
une présentation du groupe et en fait
quand on est super paraissait en
mathématiques et qu'on cherche à
économiser tous les symboles possible on
peut même essayer d'enlever ce signal et
se signale ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
m'a mis le pied des deux côtés à droite
par rome - 1 et ensuite par sylvain et
là on voit que en fait l'euro euros - 1
vont s'annuler puis le siba - sigma
vaste vont s'annuler aussi et du coup on
obtient l'identité ça ça veut dire que
si on applique sigma puis re -1 puis
sigma puis ro alors on obtient identité
et du coup le groupe engendrés par
sylvain héros va être isomorphe au
groupe engendrés par a et b avec cette
relation ici ou lorsque l'on écrit ça
comme ça on sous-entend que cette
relation là est égal à l'identité comme
ce groupe et non communicatif il
correspond à un groupe différent du
groupe fondamentale du tort du coup si
on cautionne l'espace r2 le plan aux
clients par ce groupe qui est non
commutative vont obtenir une variété
topologique qui avoir un gros
fondamentale qui est égal à ce groupe là
et qui va être donc distincts
du tort et en fait vous allez obtenir ce
qu'on appelle la bouteille de klein blé
goudé de 15 c'est un truc absolument
géniale est assez étrange dont patience
a parlé rapidement la bouteille de klein
c'est donc une veille technologique de
dimension 2 qui après joe maîtriser
comme un plan une cliente eu en lui
donne à beaune géométrie à ce moment là
la somme des angles et des faits en
gaieté à 180 degrés mais ce qui est
bizarre à cavités de car c'est qu'il
existe des lacets donc si vous suivez
ses lacets vous revenez au point de
départ et la gauche et la droite sont
toutefois inversée et en particulier si
votre univers avait cette topologie est
possible qu'elle ne sait pas si elle a
cette topologie là et qu'on suit ce
genre de chemin on reviendrait sur terre
et les orange aurait un goût de citron
et vice versa c'est sale c'est parce
qu'il ya des molécules qui donne le goût
du citron et de l'orage qui sont le
miroir 20 de l'autre bref la bouteille
de klein c'est un truc vraiment génial
vraiment trop cru
malheureusement ou heureusement le
sétois on ne peut pas la représenter
dans notre espace 3d
il ya des façons de représenter cette
bouteille de klein mais fauqué des
points d'intersection qui n'existerait
pas dans la vraie bouteille de klein
donc vous invite à aller voir ces
quelques vidéos qui parle de la
bouteille de klein sera en objets
vraiment dans les yeux
passons maintenant à un autre exemple en
passant on a commencé avec le plus
simple le cercle après on a cocciante et
le plan par un groupe commutative puis
on l'a accostée par un groupe non
commutatif maintenant ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va partir d'une des
revêtements universel initial qui est
plus peut-être plus difficile à
visualiser que le plan aux clients à
savoir vacances et avec le laisse faire
pour la série en vo comme à peu près ce
que c'est mais c'est plus étrange que ça
peut avoir l'air notamment il y a un
groupe qui agit sur la sphère qui est
l'opération qui consiste à inverser les
pôles de la terre donc chaque point va
devenir son antipode donc là on a une
transformation qui inverse un peu la
sphère dans certain sens et si on
inverse deux fois à la sphère on revient
avec la sphère initial donc c'est une
transformation qui lorsqu on lapide deux
fois donne l'identité et du coup le
groupe engendrées par cet élément va
contenir uniquement lui même et
l'identité
c'est un groupe à deux éléments donc les
groupes à douze éléments en fait y en a
qu'un seul à isomorphisme près donc ça
correspond à z sur de zz sur deux est d
un élément qui est zéro qui l'identité
puis un autre élément qui est un et un
plus car ça fait zéro donc si on fait
deux fois l'élément qui n'ont nulle qui
n'est pas identité on obtient l'élément
identité bref vous êtes sûr de z agit
sur la sphère et ont peu consciente et
la sphère par l'action du groupe e être
sur deux aides et à ce moment là on
obtient ce qu'on appelle le plan
projectif deux dimensions de l'ordre
défini comme ça ça peut paraître super
abstrait d'ailleurs on ne peut pas
représenter non plus le plan projective
dans notre espace de dimension 3 il y
aura des intersections blizzard a pu
même si vous voyez ces intersections
c'est en tout cas une [ __ ] rab izard le
plan projectif a représenté entre 4
politiquement et du coup on a
l'impression que ça existe pas vraiment
dans notre monde réel
pourtant fait c'est une composante
essentielle de beaucoup d'aspects des
mathématiques
ça paraît notamment en mécanique
quantique un pour décrire l'ensemble des
états
de l'univers est en fait il ya une autre
façon de représenter le point positif
qui peut armer peut-être de mieux
visualiser une autre façon de construire
le plan pour objectif c'est de
considérer l'ensemble des droites qui
passe par l'origine dans l'espace de
dimension 3 qu'intuitivement dans cet
espace à si vous tournez une droite de
d'un demi-tour vous revenez c'est
exactement sur la même droite mais pas
exactement cet équipement c'est la main
droite
on sent qu'il ya un truc qui est un
petit peu différent fait on va aller
dans le sens opposé de la première
droite et ça c'est en fait un indice du
fait que le la cei qui mène de ses
droits dans ce sens là dedans soit
l'autre sens est un lacet non trivial
c'est à dire qu'il est pas homo top
aulas celle qui consiste à ne pas bouger
là c'est trivial et l'existence de cela
c'est notre île a c'est à dire qu'en
fait si on déplie le plan projectif
selon cela s'est notamment et on dit que
le la sénatrice via correspondent à
définir un nouveau point on obtient deux
points différents dans la sphère de
dimension 2 qui correspond aux deux
points en typo dos d'une sphère donc
elle vous ai parlé du plan projectif
deux dimensions 2 mai à construction que
je vous ai dit elle marche dans toutes
les dimensions vous prenez une sphère
vous avez toujours être sur des aides
qui a réagi sur la haine ce faire en
inversant les antipodes où vous pouvez
toujours consciente et la sphère par ce
groupe là du coup à chaque fois l
obtenir un plan projectif mais qui va de
dimension est doux comme on écrit
parfois rpn et s'est plaint projective
vous en faites un rôle très important
notamment en géométrie algébrique comme
en parle
elle gît dans cette superbe vidéo et
tout ça m'amène au dernier exemple dont
je veux parler dans cette vidéo qui va
être encore un peu plus tendue larmes à
chaque fois on a compliqué de plus en
plus en montant de dimension en prenant
des groupes qui étaient pas forcément
commutatif et en utilisant des
revêtements universelle qui était pas
forcément simple l'astre on va prendre
un revêtement universelle est encore
plus compliqué et on va t'il y est en
fait le cas de so2 trois sauts de 3,6
l'ensemble des rotations de l'espace de
dimension 3 donc l'ensemble des
rotations de dimension 3 donc
intuitivement vous pouvez imaginer que
les rotations des dimensions 3d rotation
comme ça des rotations comme ça et des
rotations comme ça donc en gros il ya
trois composantes différentes de la
rotation de dimension 3
si vous dis ça en fait c'est pour vous
donner une intuition pourquoi elles sont
de 3 et de dimension 3 qu'elle soit 2,3
l'ensemble des rotations de dimension 3
est lui-même un espace de dimension 3
mai la topologie de dassault de trois
n'est pas si simple
en tout cas c'est pas l'espace
tridimensionnel euclidien en fait soit
2,3 et compact prenez n'importe quel de
rotation qui est déjà défini vous pouvez
ajouter une petite composante comme ça
une petite confidence comme ça où une
petite composante comme ça vous pouvez
toujours voulu déplacer dans les trois
dimensions à partir de n'importe quel
fusante et ça ça montre qu'il ya pas de
bord et intuitivement s 2 3 n'est pas
non plus un fini puisque au fait si vous
prenez une rotation ou continuer à aller
dans ce sens de cette rotation au final
bas vous allez finir par revenir
si vous tournez de 360 degrés bah vous
revenez au point initial donc voilà il
serait de 3 c'est un exemple l'espace de
dimension 3 qui est finie et 100 morts
pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle des
photos 3 dans cet épisode c'est parce
que dans les sauts de 3 il ya des lacets
qui ne sont pas triviaux et en fait on
peut les représenter par un truc qui
s'appelle la danse de ben ali
vous souvenez vous avez dit que pour le
plan projectif j'avais cette
transformation qui inversait la droite
au final c'était la même droite du coup
c'était un lacet on revenait au même
point que le point initial mais on
sentait que c'était pas un assez
triviale mais il ya la même chose qui se
passe pour un saut de 3d estime façon de
déformer des rotations pour revenir à la
rotation initial on sent qu'il ya un
truc qui coince un petit peu qui fait
que l'on n'est pas revenu exactement ça
ça va correspondre au fait que le lacet
et pas trivial donc voici le lacet dans
les sols de troie qui montre qu'il
existe des lacets non triviaux alors
attention avoir beaucoup d'imagination
s'il faut faire c'est s'appelle la danse
de ben ali vous garder la main vers
l'eau comme ça puis vous tournez la main
comme ça et là ce moment la moselle
exactement la même rotation vous tournez
en fait ce sont sept axes donc je voyais
en début là j'ai tourné selon cet axe là
sont aix de rotation est là au bout d'un
tour
je suis donc revenu à la rotation
initial j'ai fait un tour de 360 degrés
donc je suis revenu à la même rotation
donc là je suis j'ai vraiment fait un
lacet dans un trou de 3 mais là
clairement cela c'est nous montre que
même si j'ai exactement la même
orientation qu'au début
il ya un truc qui s'est passé et en fait
ça revient vraiment ça correspond
vraiment à dire que cela c'est edmond
trivial en fait si je répète c'est la
scène si je fais encore un tour de 360
degrés je reviens au point initial
classe est magique et cette illustration
en fait est une illustration du fait
qu'il existe cela c'est dans un seau de
troie qui si on le répète deux fois
devient à la c'est trivial
autrement dit le groupe fondamental de
so2 3ème set sur deux aides comme le
gros fondamentales du plan projectif et
du coup comme vous l'imaginez ce qu'on
peut faire c'est déplier so 2 3 le long
de cela c'est en disant que ce que j'ai
obtenu là en fait c'est pas la même
rotation que la rotation qui est là elle
diffère d'un assénant trivial donc si je
crée un nouveau point qui correspond à
distinguer ces deux points là je déplie
alors assauts de 3 et lorsque l'on
déplie so2 3 le long de cela c'est on
construire son revêtement universel que
l'on appelle spin de 3 est en fait la
construction que je viens de faire
essayer on peut la faire dans d'autres
dimensions
donc si on prend un espace de dimension
n est qu on regarde l'ensemble des
rotations de cet espace de dimension est
non construits assauts de hand et ce
domaine va encore avoir un lacet non
trilian si on déplie assauts de haine on
obtient sur un vêtement universelle qui
va s'appeler qu'on m'appelle spin de
haine donc a priori aucune raison pour
que on est quelconque compréhension de
spin de haine mais sauf que pour n assez
petit les espaces speedway spin de haine
correspondent à des groupes variété
assez connu spin de 3 c'est celui qui
nous intéresse le plus puisque c'est un
appareil haut de trois jusque-là spleen
de 3 lui vaty zomor far as eu 2 2 qui
est l'ensemble des matrices unités à
déterminant un de l'espace complexe
dimension 2 mais si on y réfléchit du
coup est su de 2 ça va être une variété
topologique quelle est sa dimension mais
en fait ça va être la même caisse de 3
puisque c'est en gros et sow 2 3 mais
qu'on a déplié etc on déplie des
structures en fait elles gardent leurs
dimensions donc est ce que 2 2 a encore
une dimension 3 elle est aussi compact
parce qu'on a déplié s ou de trois une
seule fois on l'a fait qu'un seul
dépliement dessous de 3 sinon cela c'est
notre idéal du coup il ya aucune raison
qu'on puisse partir à l'infini dans le
sud 2 2
en fait et sud 2-2 et compact enfin
comme on a enlevé les lacets non
triviaux il nous reste plus que des
lacets triviaux dans un sud 2-2 du coup
à l'issue de deux et simplement connexes
et sud 2 2 est donc une variété de
dimension 3 compact et simplement
connexes elle satisfait les hypothèses
de la conjecture de poincaré en la
conjecture de poincaré a été prouvée par
par herrmann
donk est de 2 et forcément la même chose
qu'une trois sphères
d'un point de vue topologique pour bien
sûr la preuve que j'ai abandonné là
c'est la preuve alambiquée qui utilise
le terme de perlman poincaré on peut
démontrer beaucoup plus facilement que
ça que l sud 2-2 et la même chose au no
more comme on dit en topologie halal
trois sphères mais du coup est de 3,1 et
sur d'autres où on a vu que lorsque l'on
dépliait selon être sur deux aides
on obtenait issus de deux donc le
dépliement seul on est sur deux aides
son groupe fondamental de so2 3 nous
donne là trois sphères vous voyez
l'ouest que j'en veux dire lorsque l'on
a plié la sphère selon être sur deux
aides
la sphère de dimensions de on a obtenu
le plan projectif deux dimensions 2 et
je vous avais dit que ça on peut le
généraliser à n'importe quelle dimension
est en effet en dimension 3 lorsque mon
plie-le j'espère selon la relation
d'antipodes quand on inversait
l'antipode on obtient à ce moment là le
plan projectif de dimension 3 et cette
construction est en fait exactement la
même que celle qui nous permet d'obtenir
et sous 2 3 donc en fait assaut de 3 et
aux morts c'est à dire c'est la même
chose que le plan projectif de dimension
3 c'est joli quand même
bon ça fait beaucoup d'informations dans
cette vidéo je rajoute une dernière qui
concerne les groupes de mots topi
d'ordre supérieur jusque là on a parlé
du groupe fondamentale qui est un
ensemble de lassay à homo topi près le
lacet c'est une fonction continue du
cercle dans une variété topologique mais
on peut généraliser ça en parlant de
l'ensemble des sphères dans une variété
topologique c'est à dire l'ensemble des
fonctions de s2 dans une variété
topologique encore une fois aux motos
pile près et on peut monter avec s3 s4
s5 et bien les groupes qu'on obtient à
chaque fois pour les dimensions
supérieures dont on peut d'ailleurs
prouvé qu'ils sont là bihan
sans ce qu'on appelle les groupes de
motos pis d'ordre supérieur est en fait
une des questions à d'apparence très
simple que se sont posée les
mathématiciens c'est qu'elle est le
groupe dommages aux pies de dendre 4 de
la sphère de dimension 6 ou plus
généralement quel est le groupe de motos
pis dans l'ordre cas de la sphère de
dimension aide et stockant fait ces
questions là sont incroyablement
difficile et comprendre les groupes que
l'on obtient ainsi est l'un des plus
grands défis de la recherche actuelle en
mathématiques
en tout cas si vous voulez marquer
l'histoire des mathématiques ben vous
pouvez vous intéresser au pica de sl il
ya pas mal qui sont calculées mais si
vous pouvez trouver des relations entre
ces pics adsl et puis les prouver les
bateaux mathias en remercierai fortement
et d'ailleurs puisque j'ai choisi de
parler de l'infini pour la prochaine
série on va parler un petit peu de la
manière dont les mathématiciens moderne
et c'est d'étudier ces groupes d'auto
pis dans vos supérieurs
moi j'espère que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo c'était persil nom est chargé pas
pu faire un truc aussi long mais juste
tellement de choses dont je voulais
parler propos de ce domaine qui est la
topologie algébrique c'est-à-dire
l'étude de la topologie à l'aide
d'outils rubriques comme par exemple les
groupes de motos pis donc une autre
partie de ce domaine des topos
j'aimerais qu'on appelle l'homologie
dont j'ai pas parlé ici aussi tout un
domaine peu plus difficile à expliquer
je trouve que les autos motos alors pour
aller plus loin à l'est malheureusement
j'ai pas de bonnes ressources en
français à vous conseiller parce que
j'ai pas appris ça en français en
anglais je peux vous recommander un
article que j'ai écrit en anglais sur
comment le poème de l'île gaz et de
l'électricité de l'eau vous avez trois
maisons le gage centrale des eau une
centrale de gaz une centrale
d'électricité
toutes les maisons doivent être liés à
toutes les centrales mais vous ne voulez
pas qu'il y ait de croisement entre les
lions comment est ce que vous faites ne
se trouvent que la solution de ce
problème est intimement liée à des
considérations de topologie algébrique
et tout ce que je peux vous recommander
celle à l'endroit où j'ai vraiment
appris tout ça lorsque pour la première
fois c'est la série de vidéos de cours
de norman weynbergh heures que je croque
monde fortement mais c'est en anglais